l'heure n'est pas encore au relâchement
de nos efforts encore moins au
relâchement de notre vigilance
collective
nous n'avons pas connu de troisième
vague et contrairement à nombre de nos
voisins nous ne sommes jamais totalement
sortie de la deuxième
comment que nous construisons la balance
entre 1 to sanitaires tout sanitaire
c'est à dire c'est le choix qui a été
fait jusqu'à maintenant de protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles et plus
anciennes et de diminuer la morbidité
mortalité par rapport à une vision qui
permet aussi et de d'avoir une france
qui vit
[Musique]
la faisabilité d'une telle mesure et a
déjà été débattu plusieurs fois depuis
un an elle est très très très discutable
la solidarité qu'elle emporte entre les
générations l'est tout autant et
l'impact épidémique n'est pas assurée
[Musique]